good afternoon everyone good afternoon
everyone
it's so good to see you here today my
name is Kevin Vaughn and I'm the
Associate Director of the Free Library
of Philadelphia and I want to welcome
you to our lecture series today we have
a couple of rules that we want to abide
by so I'm going to ask you to shut off
all of your cell phones and your pagers
as well end also there will be no
photographs in the auditorium I'm sure
that people may have brought cameras and
you'll certainly be able to use them
upstairs in the lobby afterwards but
certainly not here you may have noticed
a couple of cameras around the room this
is being filmed live for c-span for
their book program so this will be going
out over the air and because of that
during the question-and-answer period
you'll notice there are microphones in
the aisles in order to ask a question
you must go to the microphone and use
the microphone so that people both in
the auditorium and the audience at home
can hear you so thank you very much for
your participation today I'd like to
introduce to you David Johnson who is a
senior at northeast high school David
participates in a space club there and
as it turns out 40 years ago right after
his space shot scott Carpenter visited
philadelphia and visited that very same
space club at northeast high so he david
is here today as a representative of
that club to introduce you to scott
carpenter david
as you know we have a very special guest
with us today a living legend and an
American hero astronaut scott carpenter
a pioneer of modern exploration mr.
carpenter has a unique distinction of
being a Voyager of both inner and outer
space acquiring the dual title astronaut
and aqua na born in boulder colorado in
1925 mr. carpenter attended the
University of Colorado and received a
degree in aeronautical engineering he
was commissioned to the US Navy in 1949
became a naval aviator aviator in 1951
and served in the Korean War flying
anti-submarine ship surveillance and
aerial mining missions he attended the
Navy test pilot school the Navy general
line school and the Naval Air
intelligence school on april 9th 1959
mr. carpenter was selected as one of the
original seven mercury astronauts he
underwent intensive training with NASA
and was John Glenn's back a pilot for
America's first manned orbital
spaceflight on May twenty-fourth 1962
mr. carpenter flew the second American
manned orbital flight in the Aurora 7
following his historic flight carpenter
participated in the Navy's man in the
sea project in the Skylab to program
during the 45-day experiment he spent 30
days living and working on the ocean
floor he returned to duties with NASA as
executive assistant director to the
manned space flight center and was
active in the design of the Apollo lunar
landing module and in underwater extra
vehicular crew training in 1967 he
became director of aquanaut operations
for the Sealab 3 experiment which
focused on development of deep ocean
search rescue salvaged ocean engineering
and man and see capabilities he retired
from the Navy in 1969 today he lectures
frequently on the history and future of
ocean and space technology the impact of
scientific and technological advance on
human affairs Space Age perspectives the
health of planet earth and man's
continuing search fractions among his
numerous awards are the Navy's Legion of
Merit the Distinguished Flying Cross
NASA's Distinguished Service Medal US
Navy astronaut wings New York City gold
medal of honor and the Boy Scouts of
America silver buffalo in view of recent
events the heroism and bravery of early
space pioneers like
mr. carpenter are palpable we are
fortunate to have him with us today also
joining us is chris topher daughter of
scott carpenter and co-author of his
book Chris was six years old on May
twenty-fourth 1962 when her father
rocketed into space since her graduation
from Georgetown University with a degree
in history she has worked as an editor
and writer she lives with her husband
and daughter in Denver please join me in
welcoming scott Carpenter and chris
topher to the free library in
philadelphia
thank you thank you very much and thank
you for coming to this this little
celebration it is a celebration here for
for both my daughter and me I have
wanted to be at this place with the book
finished and no more work to do on it
for many many even decades I've wanted
to write about my sainted maternal
grandfather for four decades and I
talked with Chris frequently above as re
used to because she wanted to see some
honoring of her great grandfather as
well and so we talked about writing the
book and we talked about my rating the
book and we talked some more about my
writing the book and I just didn't do it
she noticed my tendency toward
procrastination so we we began speaking
in more detail and with greater urgency
about when are we going to do this we
talked with a number of good friends in
the world of literature and Chris urged
me again finally our friends helped us
to come to the decision that we should
write the book together I've certainly
needed her help excuse me and of course
I had to be present for the telling of
my story and so once that decision was
made Chris through diligent use of leg
irons and other shackles on my body got
me started on this book and then now
after three years of of effort and hard
labor we have arrived at this final
point
and it makes us both very happy I wanted
originally just to honor my grandfather
but Chris who is a great author in her
own right with 20 years as an experience
as an editor and degree in history and
an affection for genealogy and a work
ethic that wore me out uncovered in our
search for background material for this
book on my grandfather originally a
treasure trove of papers and and
historical things from our family
notable among those papers were letters
from my mother to my father let me set
the stage for that both my mother and
father attended the University of
Colorado this is in the mid 20s and
after they both graduated they were
married and i was born in boulder and at
a before i was one we all moved to New
York City where my father a gifted
chemist I've had a position developing
the processes that could synthesize
essential Musk's and oils for the
cosmetics industry it was a one in it
was the one place in the country where
he could have found that kind of work
which affected his decision to stay in
New York when they realized that my
mother was seriously ill with
tuberculosis and could not stay in New
York the conventional medical wisdom of
the mid-twenties which by the way was
without penicillin was that to cure
tuberculosis you
moved Colorado in the high dry air and
with other sometimes ineffective therapy
try to get over it so the parent my
parents were split by this disease we
moved back to boulder and my mother
began a string of years in which she was
bedridden for one period of time for
three and a half years without getting
up out of bed she had a terrible
terrible tragedy in her own life because
of that disease it split her marriage
and the split marriage ended up in a
divorce many years later but it was a
terrible trauma for for my met and my
mother but for me now in retrospect I
see that it was a marvelous stroke of
good fortune because I have come to
value the high country in Colorado and
the countryside over the low country in
New York City and and the big city i am
glad i didn't i didn't grow up in New
York City but grew up in the mountains
of Colorado that's only half the story
the other the other half of it is
although my father was a brilliant
scientist he didn't understand much
about little boys and I now see that I
am fortunate to have been delivered out
from his hands and into the hands of
that marvelous man who wasn't my
grandfather so my mother's misfortune
was my good fortune and I am of course
it changed man by reason of that
I also came away with from that
experience with some deeply held
convictions regarding the value of
grandparents even as a little boy I
remember thinking I am so lucky to have
that old man in my house telling me
things that he learned two generations
ahead of everybody else's father grandpa
new things nobody else's dad knew and I
felt very fortunate to have been
deposited more or less in his lap and to
be guided by him he was a major a major
influence on me so for the moment we
have written about grandpa and honored
him in a way that is satisfying to both
of us but because of Chris's prescient
and because of her research capability
we have honored in the writing of this
and even greater hero than my then my
grandfather and that was revealed to
Chris and then to me through my mother's
letter to do my dad who needed
instruction and how to be a father it
didn't seem to do much good but she
fought for me and she had some tough
battles that is now a part of this story
of which were both very proud the only
sad note I can attach to that is the
simple fact that I didn't know all of
this when while my mother was alive
little boys don't appreciate or at least
this little boy didn't appreciate his
mother maybe because she was a woman as
much as this little boy appreciated the
grandpa maybe because he
was a man and he did things that boys
want to grow up to do in any event the
book reveals even a greater heroes than
my grandpa and lo and behold it's my mom
and this lady discovered all of that for
which I am I am very grateful I think
that covers fairly well the the the
genesis of this book except i must say
one other thing and I'd address this to
the emerging fathers among you or even
the little boys who will be father's one
day that I have had a rare and marvelous
experience as a father and you fathers
out there can look forward to it too if
you're lucky enough to have the
experience I have had in a creative work
being done by a father-daughter team it
has been one of the greatest pleasures
of my life working with my daughter and
I am here to report happily to you that
we are still speaking and still good
friends the story takes care of my my
youth I had an unusual time in the 1930s
I was I had horses I had my own horse I
had so many things that other boys my
age didn't I don't need to go into that
in any greater detail I was blessed is
what I was standard schooling and World
War two came along and 41 I was a 1941 I
was a sophomore in high school we were
attacked and it's that turned into a
very popular war
and 17 year old high school boys in
nineteen forty one or two couldn't think
of anything better than joining of the
Navy or the army or the Marine Corp and
going off to fight fight that war
because we had been attacked and you
know it it called to the forefront or
patriotism and our macho and the
testosterone that was coming along it
was a great great challenge to all 17
year old boys a movie came out and in
those years I think maybe it was in 42
yes it was in 42 called Wake Island the
story about some marooned naval aviators
and marine aviators on wake island and
they were overwhelmed eventually by the
Japanese Navy but they fought a noble
fight and I thought those are the
greatest men and the greatest heroes I
can imagine I want to be one of them
because they and I think this is an
important distinction I have to make I
didn't and have never wanted to be a
hero but I wanted to be an aviator in
those days because I wanted to fight for
my country everybody wanted that but
then following that period I fell in
love with flying and that is what i
wanted to do with or without the
possible attendant heroism any event I
got out of school out of high school
joined the navy flight training program
the schools were full at that time they
sent Navy sent me to college for a year
finally got into flight training of a
lot of
tarmac duty and pre-flight duty and by
the time the the atom bomb had been
dropped and the war was over I had
accumulated eight hours of flying time
yeah and a little by yellow biplane
called a Yellow Peril Stearman n2s
marvelous experience that is unavailable
to naval aviators training today because
it number one it has four wings instead
of just two and it has a propeller
instead of a jet engine but that was
still a marvelous experience the war was
over i decided i would go back to school
i ultimately got a very important item
in my in my portfolio and that was a
degree in aeronautical engineering
remember that it comes up later I didn't
really want to work as an engineer I
might love for flying persisted and I
joined the Navy and and went back to
fight training but this time with the
wife and the small son which led to a
fateful decision notnot fateful it
wasn't people that it was an
excruciating decision between being a
fighter pilot and being a patrol people
pilot big airplane pilot that that was
at the time of the Korean War and what
went through my mind and maybe it is a
rationalization today I'm not certain
but it occurred to me that with a son at
home and another one on the way I have
no right to choose a profession within
the naval aviation community that was
that was more pep that
that put my children's father's life in
greater peril then it should have people
flying in those days was a lot safer I
figured and so I didn't get to be at
that time the fighter pilot I wanted to
be I flew the big airplanes it finally
worked out okay but it was an
excruciating decision I had to make so I
started my first duty with the Navy a
patrol plane squadron that operated out
of Honolulu I finally discovered my
great love and affection and curiosity
about the deep ocean first time I have
done any scuba diving or any
spearfishing and I was hooked I also had
an experience there that Aria revealed
to me that I had a an unreasoned fear of
the deep ocean with which I was very
uncomfortable I was afraid unreasonably
afraid of the sharks that I expected to
find in deep ocean water we didn't know
much about sharks in those days and and
they were frightening to me beyond
reason and i found that unreasoned fear
very uncomfortable that was an important
issue in in my Navy work in Hawaii out
of that squadron duty I was fortunate
enough to be appointed to the Navy's
test pilot school and that it gained me
another very important item for my
portfolio I would finally get to fly jet
fighters and I would be a test pilot and
in four or five years it turned out when
on both sides of the Iron Curtain it
began to be realized that here with our
ICBMs we have the capability by changing
trajectory and changing payload little
too large artificial satellites with
with our ICBM boosters then it became
apparent that we could put life on these
satellites first dogs or monkeys and
then we could launch men who would orbit
the Earth an incredible new scientific
achievement which over the last 40 years
has changed the character for ever more
of the United States more about that I
hope later in any event when it became
apparent that we could fly men in orbit
around the earth President Eisenhower
okayed it and his answer to the question
who shall we put aboard this this
orbiting spacecraft and he said we have
to choose from among the ranks of jet
qualified military test pilots with a
degree in aeronautical engineering or of
related science and so it all sort of
fell in place for me there were 550 of
those men at that time a lot of good men
were not considered because they grew
taller than 5 feet 11 inches a lot of
good men were not considered because
they didn't go to college and didn't
have that degree notable among those who
were not called is the Dean of all test
pilots Chuck Yeager but he was okay with
that he had he had done his share by the
and we had his unmitigated support for
our project that did not obtain with a
lot of other test pilots at the time but
it's to Chuck's credit that that he saw
the value and what we were doing I was
at that time air intelligence officer
attached to the US as Hornet and we were
getting ready to deploy to the attack
carrier to the southwest Pacific and i
got these orders as did all of the other
people who eventually were asked to
volunteer for Project Mercury I got
these orders that said you will come to
Washington by such and such a time we
reported to the Pentagon and the orders
further stated that that you will not
discuss or speculate with anyone
including your commanding officer the
reason for these orders they were signed
by see a no CNO for the uninitiated in
navy lingo stands for Chief of Naval
Operations he's the top sailor in the
world in our opinion and see you know to
the junior naval officer CNO is two
steps above God
and when you get orders from him you do
what they say which I did my wife and I
grass Chris's mother and I sort of
speculated and I must tell you I did
tell my wife about the orders and we
speculated we saw an arctic article in
the in Time magazine that said something
about these men being ordered to
Washington to fly something new and fast
and exciting and it turned out to be
right so we went through a fascinating
selection period that I could go into
vast detail with you about but it was a
fascinating time and although the way it
was detected depicted in the right stuff
what you may have seen and by the
newspapers it sounded painful and hard
work and it hip really wasn't the only
hard work in space flight or even even
in the training or in the selection for
Space Flight is writing the centrifuge
that's hard work but it's fascinating
and so you don't think about how hard it
is there is nothing really painful about
it either it was just a fascinating
period getting the machine and the human
body ready to take on this as marvelous
new challenge can we build a machine
that can fly around the earth in orbit
and keep a man alive inside that was one
challenge to our curiosity the other was
to those of us who would be aboard can I
train can we train our bodies to do this
incredible thing the answer to both of
those questions was yes it was a
resounding triumph of medical technology
and arrows what became aerospace
technology and
it was a major accomplishment for this
nation when we got into the act of
flying men in orbit because we ended up
being led by we we were playing catch-up
with the Soviet Union they were way
ahead of us and for very good reasons
and we played catch up with them for a
long time but we finally we finally got
back into the business and American
superiority finally claimed the prize
not because Americans are better people
than Russians but because Americans are
free and the and democracy as a
governing system is superior to
communism and this I've heard that mouth
everywhere and kind of think it's like
singing alma mater but it is a truth we
won that a space race to the moon not
because we were better but because the
Soviets lost the race by reason of the
other' communism it's that simple so
anyway let's see where um where am I in
this story this is documented in the
book of fairly fairly well those were
those were marvelous times in the early
sixties when we were doing battle with
the Soviet Union excuse me for supremacy
in space I have to mention a couple of
crucial contributors to our winning of
the of the race and that is in the form
of
of the man who galvanized this nation
behind flying to the moon it was john f
kennedy's vision and and charisma and
what he had been able to do for this
country with his with his organization
in Washington he said through his vision
we must go to the moon before the end of
this decade and the return safely and
the country listened and we did his
bidding that was crucial to the Apollo
program and following in his footsteps
was the other crucial contributor named
Wernher von Braun the German scientist
who built who showed us how to get where
Kennedy wanted us to be it was his
blinding genius that did it and he is
one of the unsung heroes that I'd like
to mention there were a number of others
within NASA our book tells their story
they were gifted engineers who got
overwhelmed by a group of seven famous
astronauts a long time ago and never got
much credit for the marvelous work they
did Paul purser max PJ and guide
Thibodeau Chris and I will meet them in
Houston and we'll ask him if they know I
haven't really thought of that but I'm
what I know Chris wants to find out and
I want to find out it is are they happy
that they finally get some recognition
in print for their monumental
achievements that are a lot of unsung
heroes like that it's time now just to
mention briefly another experience that
we speak
of some in the book and that's the
underwater work with Sealab I finally
realized after my flight with NASA that
we were developing technology and
techniques and a body of knowledge in
NASA directed to keeping people alive in
space that could be used in shakib
Cousteau's program of keeping men alive
in the ocean I said to my boss Bob
Gilbert I would like to go see Cousteau
offer my services to him see if I could
be a member of his diving team and share
some of our technology with what he was
doing and maybe bring some of their
technology back to NASA the good captain
was speaking at MIT I made my proposal
to him and he said well we could use
your technology and that Iver say they'd
accept you as a buddy diver but you
don't speak the right language and we
can't pay you very much but the transfer
of technology is worthwhile why don't
you do it with your own navies program
excuse me and it was through justo that
I met George bond Papa topside the the
the man who was responsible for the
development of a saturation diving which
is now in use around this globe for
deepwater search and salvage and
recovery efforts it's a major
contribution that was done by your Navy
so I i joined the Sealab program and
began to transfer technology both ways
I'll give you one story about this
technology transfer a lot of it worked
very well but I will speak to you about
one it is a shark chaser that huge
NASA had had commissioned of the
development of that would drive sharks
away from returning capsules in the
Bahamas we had recovered some mercury
capsules with evidence of shark attack
when one phenolic heat shield there was
a shark tooth embedded in it NASA didn't
like the idea of losing a returning
space he wrote to shark attack on the
water so this handsomely funded develop
on program was started I knew about this
I was at Panama City with the sea level
one team and we had our own fears of
sharks we had a shark cage that we all
envisioned going down into a few go up
over the diving trunk and peering around
everywhere and seeing there are no
sharks around and I would go out and do
whatever work there was so i said if
this thing works we could use it to I
asked Gill Ruth to send a copy of it to
dr. Perry Gilbert on a navy consultant
at the mote marine laboratory a world
expert in shark behavior we asked him to
evaluate this shark taser for us he kept
it in his sharp bends for a couple of
weeks sent it back to dr. Gill Ruth NASA
with his evaluation letter and a copy to
me at Panama City I have to give you
visualize for you what this thing is
it's a cylinder 810 inches long seven
inches in diameter with battery power
some hydraulics some gears and motors
and on/off switch and some some other
equipment that would be automatically
ejected from the spacecraft when it
lands be turned on sit in the water of
the antenna would extend and it would
emit into the water
electro magnetic and electric electronic
and lick true sonic and all sorts of
signals that would drive the Sharks away
that was the idea Perry Gilbert letter
said we have evaluated your electronic
shark chaser in our shark pens and find
it mildly repellent to sharks in both
the on and off position so that in that
event the technology transfer was not
too helpful except it saved money for
the taxpayers because if it wasn't
working any better than that NASA
decided we will cut that program back
and it saved a lot of money because its
development was stopped we I have to
tell you never had any difficulty with
with marauding sharks in the space
program or in Sealab we know a lot more
about sharks now than we did then it's
just another one of the unknowns that
that we have made known in both the deep
diving program and in and in NASA after
that I went back after the Sealab
program I went back to to NASA I worked
with a zero-g facility where we develop
extra vehicular procedures for men who
would work outside their spacecraft that
was a vital transfer of technology from
the ocean to NASA and it was it was a
very good cooperation between NASA and
the Navy
let's see there was one other important
item I wanted to to bring in here I
think it is the fact that first of all I
hate to choose between you i hate to
answer a question which would you rather
do fly in space or or dive to the ocean
floor i hate to make that decision
because i feel very fortunate to have
had a chance to do both I realize now
that my decision to go to go to Sealab
and ultimate his decision to leave NASA
and an abandoned Space Flight was a
crucial decision that I made and it
amounted to a staggering loss to a jet
qualified Navy test pilot with an
engineering degree I gave up a chance at
a out of at a lunar landing I did
however consoled myself honestly with no
I was consoled by the simple fact that
although I had lost that marvelous
opportunity I had in its stead my work
on the ocean floor with a crew of some
of the greatest unsung heroes I've ever
known those are the the divers who the
Navy and civilian divers that I worked
with in Sealab and that that experience
is almost as satisfying to me as having
written this book with my daughter has
been and i think i probably have used up
my time I don't know
got the clock here but i have to thank
you for your attention the rest of the
time i think is to be spent with a Q&A
which my daughter will now rule and
we're going to sit over here and if you
have any questions use the aisle mics
and i think there's one in the back
there and one right here and you could
form a line if you have questions and
we'll take will take your question isn't
she pretty
yeah it's good afternoon I must have
been ten there abouts when all of my
little buddies would crowd into a school
auditorium in South Jersey and watch
teeny little black-and-white TV sets
that hardly anybody could see from the
back rows watching this fascinating
adventure of crazy people flying up on
these bombs and doing something that our
parents and their parents and nobody
else could possibly imagine doing we've
gotten through the cuban missile crisis
on our doorstep our parents had been on
the beaches fighting for the world's
freedom and now you guys were just doing
this unimaginable thing that filled
every school kid in america with a pride
in country and a pride in achievement
that we knew we could never touch unless
we happen to be part of a lucky seven
sometime in our future but as has been
made clear in the past few weeks today
maybe ninety nine percent of americans
don't even know that a machine and
people are out in space until something
tragic happens on the way back it is not
a part of our national daily pride until
the headlines forces to confront that
and i was wondering if you could speak
to what you've seen in this evolution
over 40 years from a point where your
space flights where the ultimate drama
of our lives to the point we're at today
we're the only drama of space flight for
better or for worse comes only with a
tragedy that puts it right in our faces
the only real difference I can see we
now as this pin code number one is that
we've been there and done that now it's
no longer involved which is part of the
reason people don't pay attention to get
too easy come later and we are
complacent about this marvelous new
picture we've got in place mission the
other thing I think is the reasonable
through the simple fact that space
flight is not without risk and a lot of
people you know when we get out of the
novelty and keep doing it over and over
and over you lose ten lose sight of the
fact that it's still a risky business
and the difference between then and now
again is although it's still risky there
are fewer unknowns now than there were
then because we have done it before with
the express purpose of removing the
unknown well we have accidents like this
people get scared I guess there is a
falling back and regrouping and after
the grief is
the constellations are given and they
say should we really be doing this why
did we risk these applied some say let's
don't send box let Senate machines it's
all very short-sighted and it will not
and your we always follow that
reevaluate we look at the data we have
we find the root cause and we fix it and
we press on and that's the way it should
be and it will be this time to what I
think a lot of bystanders who tend to
second-guess what it is we're doing
forget is again twofold there are people
who think we should just send machines
and not men it is a fact that machines
can do things men can't but men can do
things machines can't and we need both
in our exploration of space camp do it
alone many examples of this but the most
succinctly I think of is a remark that
the one of my comrades made General Tom
Stafford a lunar visitor he said knowing
the value of support of the American
people to the space program he said who
would give a parade down new york city
streets for a robot
and he's right robots don't capture our
attention we will find the root cause
and we will fix it and wheel back we'll
be back in in the Space Flight business
which for the for the time being and
this is not just my belief this is what
I consider an absolute inevitability
will soon be with men in permanently
manned outposts on Mars that's our
ultimate goal for right now and this
recent Columbia is just a blip on the
progress we will make toward that in and
thanks for asking the question mr.
carpenter and two part question just
wonder can you go back in time and your
emotions and describe for us or
recapture for us what it felt like that
first experience of being out in space
and part two if you could in light of
the recent events would you do it again
okay the the physiological impact of
prolonged weightlessness is the most
marvelous thing I've ever had it it's
hard to explain to those who haven't had
it but it is it is transcending as is
the view and it's addictive and they are
overwhelming impressions many I think
any man who or any human who orbits who
gets a chance at spaceflight and has a
soul is infected spiritually by the
experience some are affected
religiously it's an overwhelming
experience and it is hard to it's hard
to explain it to those who haven't been
there but it's so but thank you for
asking that question too because it
gives me a chance to say to those of you
who are going to get a chance everybody
will in the next two or three decades to
fly in space this will give you great
expectations because it's a marvelous
thing consider it if you had the
opportunity to do it again and i know
you i have another story for that when
you know John Glenn fought hard for that
flight he saw he could bring home some
new science for for the medical
profession in equating his performance
as he became an older man and the
effects on that odor man's body of
weightlessness as an interesting
scientific study I was very happy for
money finally got an okay for that
flight and I said to him that I'd be
happy to stand by for him again
but this time I've made sure he broke
his leg so I could take the fight I
added briefly after that that NASA
probably wouldn't allow that because I'm
not old enough what I've read you and
the other mercury astronauts were all a
very close-knit Bunch when you were
first selected and going through all the
training to get into space how close who
was your closest friend among that group
and how close are the remaining members
of are you today John Glenn and I and
Chris could could could vouch for this
John Glenn and I have been a pretty
steady bonded pair throughout all this
time we were neighbors in and Texas
crisp grew up with the two great glen
kids and we've been very very close for
a very long time i have felt for a long
long time that the bond the seven
mercury astronaut had with each other
the esprit de corps and the camera turi
probably didn't have an equal anywhere
else in the world that's that may be
self-serving but i believe it is true
with the possible exception of the same
bond between the early cosmonauts and so
John and I are still close the bond
exists and it will endure and we are now
down to a two number of four
alphabetically carpenter Cooper Glenn
and sure ah but we're still very close
and we see each other frequently uh well
let's take off like when you're in the
redstone rocket what was take off like
when you were on the red stone oh yeah
the the red stone was a smaller rocket
the delivered just enough thrust to get
to get up to about 115 miles and down
range 500 miles those were called
ballistic flights you really are like
bullet the take-off the take-off gets to
11 GS which is higher than the Atlas
takes you but the acceleration time is
shorter but it's still a tough you know
this is like writing the centrifuge it's
hard work and the pg's peak at eleven on
a normal lunch and peak at about 11 on a
normal recovery in a yahoo the Atlas yep
this is Peaks up on lunch at eight
degrees 8 2 g's and the recovery goes to
about 8 g on the shuttle since we have
throttle labelled rocket the peak
acceleration on lunch is 3 g's and it
can be tailored to 3 g's on entry
grandma's can do that that's another way
of saying the days of the iron man are
over mr. carpenter just going back to
the original mercury 7 astronauts I
wanted to know if you could talk a
little bit about your lapel pin not
everybody can see it yeah that's it's an
interesting story I think the Greeks
gave all the planets symbols Venus they
gave when you're familiar with it's a
circle and a plus it's also for women
they gave Mars a circle with an arrow
it's also for man for mercury they gave
the planet the symbol Venus the circle
with a plus but they put a little arch
on the top after the symbol
mercury when we all first got together
the seven of us we went to San Diego to
visit a convair plant where the where
the Atlas missile was made and before we
got there they went to a local jeweler
and asked him to make something for us
in the form of its at the lapel pin now
but in those days it was a tie tack and
a cuff links that was appropriate to the
seven mercury astronauts and he came up
with the symbol for planet mercury with
a seven in the center of the circle it
is a treasured possession for all of us
mercury folks and it except that it sits
in on pad 14 at Cape Canaveral and n
stupendous stainless steel glory about a
feet high by the by the entrance to the
pad it's a very clever and and highly
treasured figured to me and I wear it
now and then right here there's there's
a youngster here I was a te in space how
hard was it to eat Oh what hard was it
to eat well how hard it no the thing is
once you get going that fast it's real
easy to stay there you just Coast all
the way around the world until you slow
down and then you come back in but it's
a very easy job but how hard is it to
eat he was asking about eating oh how
hard it is it to eat that was a question
many many learned scientists asked the
40 years ago we didn't know that a man
would be able to eat that he would be
able to digest his food that was one of
the unknowns which now seems silly but
was still a mysterious unknown and we
know now that it's as easy to eat in
space as it is here maybe even a little
easier it's harder to hold on to what
you've got on your blade but it's easy
to eat it let me tell you another thing
it might interest you I was John's back
up as you may know and I was in the
blockhouse and during the countdown and
as it occurred to me that the only thing
John needed for this first orbital
flight was speed the guys al and Gus had
done the ballistic flight went through
the same thing same acceleration of
everything but they didn't have a
booster a rocket beneath them that could
get him to 18,000 miles an hour they got
to maybe fifty five hundred miles an
hour so the only thing John needed was
speed and it occurred to me that that
that would make his flight and sort of
as a bon voyage and sort of as a goodbye
to her safe flight to a friend and sort
of as a silent prayer that's where
silent godspeed john glenn came from we
just all we wanted for him was speed and
I can't say that those four words didn't
work and you have a question yes I'm
nervous and sitting here waiting for
this opportunity I saw Edwin Aldrin when
he was here and that was a very riveting
discussion that we had as well as was
today especially when you're talking
about the program the early program I'm
49 I grew up very close to the Aerojet
general plant in rancho cordova I don't
know if you're ever out there but my dad
said a lot of people
a lot of the astronauts did come out
there so we heard the tests and we heard
when there was a couple explode
explosions anyway I still follow the
space program I mean especially in these
times when you hear you know like
everyday discussion is about germ
warfare and gas and all the six stuff
you know I go look at my map of Mars and
that just you know able to exit all this
I know that you must have a great love
of the ocean from your experience and I
think people many people in my
generation have really a lot of just
very visceral pain looking at the
destruction that's happened since those
days when you first went down oceans
have changed quite a bit as far as i
know from other divers people that I
talk to you know fish stocks are
collapsing you know there's mercury in
the tuna it's just it's very uh anyway I
just wondered if you could say anything
about that why doesn't anybody speak up
you know people like you and i'm not
putting putting them on the spot you
know you have so much more power than
somebody like me and you know why isn't
there more and also i just one closing
thought I wish that it would be so great
if all that astronauts could form some
kind of Confederation you know everybody
that's still here and really speak out
fervently you know you're not in the
understated way that everybody is now
you know with a book tour or something
but to really push it you know to make
it more of a national issue you know not
not just kind of accepting the way
things are because they are nickel and
nickel and diming NASA and you know look
at all the money that's wasted with all
this other stupid stuff well you know
you bring up an interesting point but I
would remind you that a lot of these
terrible depredations and degradation of
our planet have become apparent to us
through the money we spend on Space
Flight it is the key to first
discovering where we are doing wrong and
we can't fix it unless we can see it
that's a that's one of the
justifications for spending all of this
money on space exploration and ocean
exploration first you got to understand
the problem and we solve it with the new
knowledge we gain with this with a
scientific investigation across the
board I wish I knew how to do it better
up like you do but I know that the quest
for new knowledge is the right way to
start I see a lot of articles in
magazines you know United States owns
the high ground just got you know
talking about the militarization of
space we're the superpower we have you
know we're in this position and I find
that also i'm not i was in the navy i'm
not a peacenik but it's just really
disturbing to think of all that stuff
might be out there I mean you know in
this pristine beautiful environment we
start putting all that stuff yeah we're
in a position of great power and
responsibility and we have to treat that
position with great care I agree yes
okay I'm
all my life I've been interested in
space and space travel and at the moment
actually considering being being an
astronomer as a career and I have a
sister who's wanted to be a fighter
pilot or an astronaut for as long as I
can remember and I just want to know
when you were out there in space and
nothing between you and like that
vastness but the walls of the spaceship
were you afraid yeah that's question is
asked frequently I was once standing
next to Al Shepard when a little old
white-haired lady said to him weren't
you afraid and his answer was no ma'am I
was concerned al was constitutionally
unable to admit fear it's like Daniel
Boone said I never been lost in the
woods I was bewildered for four days was
but to fear it's misunderstood it's
God's it's God's Way of giving you
survival capability fear makes you do
lots of things better when you're on the
freeway driving you're a little bit
afraid and that's good because it makes
a better driver out of you it's
clinically proven that fear will make
you stronger it improves your vision it
reduces your reaction time it does all
sorts of good things for you if it is
used fear is a good cockpit companion if
it is used you just got to use it if you
don't use it that's panicked and that's
not good and that's really what L was
saying he might have said that he was
concerned but what he meant was that he
was afraid but not panicked
I think we have time for one more
question yes young lady um with the
American astronauts do they have any
contact with the Russian cosmonauts
before so use one yes we you know for a
long long time we competed in a friendly
way but in sort of a secretive way with
the cosmonauts because they didn't tell
us much about what they were doing but
we each has a group at great respect for
the other in after the Apollo flights we
started both among the Soviets and the
Americans a group called association of
space explorers if its membership is
composed of cosmonauts and astronauts
who have flown in space we are all great
comrades now we have an organization of
very respectful people of each other and
it is a it's a marvelous group and
they're fine bunch of fellows they're
cut from the same block that we are and
it is a source of great pleasure for
both the cosmonauts and the astronauts
that we are now we are now cooperating
that's good competing is good too it's a
big driver but we cooperate now and
that's that's good too and so we're all
friends now it's about time as a matter
of fact let me just end this on that I
think that the friendly and driving
competition we add with the Soviets
throughout say free the the space race
I think that that kept us out of World
War three they're competitive people we
are too we had this marvelous glowing
opportunity to compete with each other
in in the quest for space that kept us
out of a shooting war I think and I'm
glad it worked out that way well I guess
we're ready to start the book signing
and what I think we're going to do
thank you very much